hello and welcome to the seventh
fundamental investing with the use of
programming tutorial where we left off
we found ourselves becoming pretty
limited with this SP 500 list and we
really need to expand this list before
we can really move forward initially I
thought we could just get over the
principles and you guys could do
whatever you wanted to do in the future
but I imagine that pretty much almost
all of you guys are gonna want to move
on to the Russell 3000 or greater and so
that's what I think we're going to do in
this video originally I thought you know
we'll maybe move to the S&P 1500 then
maybe the Russell 2 that maybe finally
the Russell 3 but why not just get it
over with show you guys how to do the
Russell 3000 so there's no easy way to
do it we're gonna have to use
programming just to get all of them just
the tickers that we want for the Russell
3000 use in our program here and you
know just make it into an array like
this right that our program can use and
work with and luckily you know that's
kind of the benefit of having the skill
of programming on your side because you
can do all of these things and so it
really is just a huge empowerment to you
if you do learn to use programming even
if you're doing like a skill like
fundamental investing which historically
it doesn't mean very much programming
but you can't use it so it's very
helpful just another reason to do it so
to get this Russell 3000 list the what
we're going to do is first go to Google
and we're gonna search for the Russ it
moves on us Russell 3000 go there go to
Russell comm basically and you can see
we arrive at Russell 3000 index you can
jump to membership that's what we're
looking for and they give us a complete
membership list PDF not the format we
want but we can work with this so click
that and you should have a window pop up
like this and this is your whole list
and obviously we don't want the PDF so
I'm going to save this we just want we
really just want the tickers you know if
only there was a way to just get the
ticker list but anyway oh good
reason you might be able to find
somebody on the internet who like has
listed out the ticker list but kind of
the reason you want to go to Russell
3000 for this is it needs to be updated
and you know obviously with this top
3000 list its who out you know those
those bottom probably I don't know 2500
companies might change fairly frequently
as opposed to the top you know the S&P
500 companies don't change as frequently
so just keep that in mind it's good to
go ahead and get it from this site so
the next thing we want to do I'm just
going to just ctrl a to highlight
everything and then ctrl C we're gonna
copy everything and now we're gonna want
to do is put this in a text document
somewhere and it just so happens I have
one somewhere in my directory okay so
bring up the directory where you've got
all your files in it and just do you
know like a new text document and I'm
just going to call it the Russell 3000
so that's what's going to what it's
going to be hit enter again bring it up
and now control V paste it in there and
then now let's do a quick bit of
housekeeping real quick first of all at
the end here you can see that it does
this as a bubble bubble blah we're gonna
get to that cuz that's kind of
problematic for now we can at least
delete that one and then delete so now
it ends with this company ticker and as
we scroll up you'll see we have some
more of these as of you know we'll deal
with that in just a minute so scroll all
the way up to the top and then get rid
of some of this other stuff like as it
starts here okay let's go back to the
bottom make sure we didn't have an extra
line no okay so now we're good so save
that now the next thing we want to do is
get rid of that as of so the next thing
we want to have is notepad plus plus if
you don't have no we've had plus you
could do it with programming but it's
just gonna be a lot easier with notepad
plus plus if you don't have notepad plus
plus go download notepad plus plus we
should be able to use google notepad
plus plus install it here is you know
Google search notepad plus plus then you
could go SourceForge and download it
okay
so just download it
and so anyway once you've downloaded it
yeah maybe pause this if you have to
download it once you've downloaded it go
to edit with notepad plus plus and we'll
come over here and drag it over now we
see okay this is the stuff right
everything is the same right it's as a
bla bla bla bla so highlight just one of
these examples where you have as of and
copy it just in case but you should be
able to do ctrl F and it should already
be there go over to the replace tab come
down here delete and then replace all so
basically it's gonna find every instance
of as of six twenty eight twenty
thirteen Russell indexes replace all
it's replacing them with nothing
basically so now you can see that's done
save that and then exit out of it and
we're done with that so now we've got a
full list of basically just the
companies and then their taker right so
that's a start but really we just want
the ticker right so now we're gonna work
on getting rid of you know the company
name and then just pulling just the
ticker and so i'ma stop video here in
the next video we'll be talking about
this time we actually will make a
program to do this part getting just the
ticker building it into an array so we
can actually use this array so if that
sounds interesting to you stay tuned the
next video as always thanks for watching
thanks for your support and your
subscriptions and until next time